[Música]
esta es la primera vez en toda mi
carrera que me subo a una charla test
con papel en mano hago esto porque
realmente la información que les tengo
que entregar es muy muy importante y no
quiero perder ni un solo punto de lo que
les tengo que decir
hace un año tuve la oportunidad de estar
en esta misma alfombra entre text
guadalajara hablando sobre la industria
de la moda y por qué es tan laxa con los
temas de esclavitud laboral y su balance
con el medio ambiente no es coincidencia
que hoy tengamos un despertar de
conciencia y que por ende seamos más
cuidadosos en la manera en la que
compramos o consumimos sin embargo el
cambio climático la percepción que
tenemos del mismo y la manera en la que
ha cambiado o ha afectado a nuestra vida
pues prácticamente ha sesgado poco a
poco la estás gado poco a poco la visión
que tiene cada individuo y nos ha
llevado a la poca o nula acción para
trabajar estratégicamente con el tiempo
hemos entendido que esto no solamente es
de la industria de la moda esto ha
sobrepasado los límites y podemos decir
que todos los productos y servicios que
están en el mercado han contribuido a la
degradación ecológica vale
el encabezado de este y los próximos
años
hablan sobre el cambio climático y de
aquí surgen tres grupos peculiares de
personas que forman una gran mayoría
suficientes para ser considerados dentro
de los estudios de cambio climático en
latinoamérica y américa del norte el
primer grupo lo conforman las personas
positivas son aquellos que dicen si hay
un problema somos conscientes de ello
tratamos de hacer lo que esté a nuestro
alcance para poder solucionarlo y son
los portavoces oficiales de que es
verdad aquí está nos va a afectar a
todos queramos o no pero este perfil
tiene un problema que hay muy fácilmente
en la ansiedad y en la psicosis de la
desinformación entonces toda acción que
ésta genera eventualmente se vuelve
inútil
qué pasa
no hay una capacidad de análisis no hay
una capacidad de análisis de reflexión
sobre los problemas este perfil en
específico termina siendo el primer
consumidor de un fenómeno llamado green
washing green washing es una medida
mercado lógica para vender los productos
verdes que no son tan verdes en realidad
no nos transparenta la información de su
proceso de producción como están hechos
y no satisfacen necesidades a largo
plazo todo al momento en este instante
un ejemplo de esto son los potes de
acero
contaminan muchísimo más en su proceso
de producción que en realidad en el
ciclo de vida útil entonces pues con
honestidad realmente es tan difícil
beber del vaso
de verdad
estamos siguiendo una tendencia
después tenemos el segundo grupo este
segundo grupo está conformado por lo que
yo los llamo los pesimistas son personas
que reconocen y dicen que absolutamente
nada
está sucediendo ellos literal te dicen
por favor consume nada está pasando de
qué estás hablando sus objetivos están
basados en sus intereses personales y
bueno en su mayoría son monetarios usan
los productos sustentables de manera
mercado lógica y aceptan naturalmente el
descenso de la humanidad así nos vamos a
morir todos bien vámonos ok a mí este
perfil es el que me parece más peligroso
de todos porque es el que frena la
innovación la optimización y la
conciencia y en vez de intentar hacer
algo frena por completo y deforma el
futuro de las siguientes generaciones
con motivos egoístas y cobardes
el siguiente grupo el tercero está
conformado por el perfil ignorante son
estas personas que realmente no tienen
ni la menor idea de qué es el cambio
climático yo solo dicen ah bueno hace un
poco más de frío o hace un poco más de
calor ya está no pasa nada y no les
interesa tampoco investigar no se
asustan no investigan todo bien ok se
mantienen indiferentes pero si eres
indiferente realmente qué pasa contigo o
sea eres inútil no estás haciendo nada
por hacer algo nada nada ahí te quedas
entonces bueno pues si crees que no es
real entonces tú crees que lo que tú
haces no afecta para nada usualmente
usan palabras como por uno no pasa nada
no solo soy yo no va a pasar nada todo
bien le suenan familiares estos perfiles
algunos de ustedes se reconoce bajo
estas características
ouch
esta es la gráfica de la percepción del
cambio climático en latinoamérica vale
está basada en la red de indicadores de
ciencia y tecnología si la observamos
bien nos daremos cuenta que los colores
amarillos presenta personas que no están
de acuerdo en que existe el cambio
climático luego que las personas que sí
están de acuerdo y algunos que no saben
nada esto es complejo de explicar
vale
después están norteamérica personas que
reconocen y creen que el cambio
climático está sucediendo o va a pasar
ok esto quiere decir que algo está
pasando hay un despertar de consciencia
pero estas gráficas no son comunes por
sí solas resulta que la percepción que
tú tienes sobre un problema está basado
en tu estatus socioeconómico entonces
las personas de clase medio medio alta
digo medio medio baja son mucho más
conscientes de que existe un problema
pero no tienen acción no pueden hacer la
gran cosa para cambiar sin embargo las
personas que están mucho más conscientes
de los temas del cambio climático son
personas de estatus socioeconómico medio
alto y ellos lo niegan lo niegan en
absoluto
entonces algo está sucediendo por acá no
creen
si somos más personas que reconocemos
que hay un problema porque no se está
haciendo nada de manera inmediata muy
bien permítanme ejemplificar les esto
con el cambio homeostático de una rana
si ustedes tienen una olla y lo pone en
agua a hervir punto de ebullición y
meten una rana dentro de esta olla la
rana va a saltar porque la habéis
quemado estamos de acuerdo
pero si tú tienes otra olla le pones
agua y poco a poco vas elevando la
temperatura de la olla con la rana
dentro la rana va a adaptar su sistema
homeostático con la temperatura y ahora
esto hasta morir hervida
y la verdad es que no me gusta ser obvia
pero pues creo que somos las ranas no
es importante entender que el sentido
individualista nos aísla de la realidad
social y nos enajena de la toma de
decisiones
si la decisión es individual el impacto
será global si el impacto es global las
consecuencias se verán reflejadas de
manera individual
aún
pero bueno no todo está perdido
siempre he creído que la tecnología es
la herramienta más resiliente creada por
la humanidad y que si la usamos
adecuadamente aún podemos hacer algo y
tener una esperanza de generar un cambio
al darles la bienvenida a la cuarta
revolución industrial quiero invitarles
a quitar de su palabra a quitar de su
vocabulario la palabra no sé
la cuarta revolución industrial habla de
la digitalización habla de la tecnología
de que todo lo tenemos a la mano en el
momento en el que lo retiramos y esto
significa que la información está en
constante cambio hacia nosotros entonces
si tú puedes buscar información de
manera inmediata se vale decir no sé yo
creo que no
creo que esto debe ser un accionador
para empezar a ser mucho más conscientes
y reflexivos sobre lo que hacemos en el
día al día y de esta manera poder ser
conscientes de cómo impactamos de manera
individual y de manera global
muy bien dentro de la gama de las nuevas
iniciativas surgen los pilares de
migración tecnológica nuevos materiales
y transformación de la materia cada una
conecta ciencia tecnología e industria
que en mi caso es la industria de la
moda biotecnología mecánica
digitalización poco a poco irán
cambiando tener naturaleza es mucho más
digital es si queremos cambiar el cambio
climático debemos apoyar este tipo de
iniciativas que quizá en este momento
nos parezcan un poco locas como las
pieles de nopal los zapatos 3d que
puedes probarte a través de realidad
aumentada o incluso prendas realizadas
de desechos marinos oímos mucho hablar
sobre las pieles veganas que son
materiales hechos a partir de cierta
cantidad de vegetales compuestos libres
de animal o compuesto animal después
tenemos las pieles vegetales que si
siguen siendo pieles animales con un
contenido de anilinas vegetales esto
quiere decir que si siguen siendo pieles
sí pero que son mucho menos
contaminantes en su proceso de teñido
después tenemos los materiales transform
transformacionales son todos esos
materiales que surgen a través de los
residuos de un proceso mecánico de
reciclado
pueden cambiar plásticos o cualquier
otro material contaminante dentro del
medio ambiente después tenemos los
recuperados orgánicos que surgen del
reciclado de los materiales que son
naturales como por ejemplo el reciclado
de las pieles y la verdad es que cada
uno de estos materiales ha surgido de
una manera rápida pero estratega sobre
la solución de problemas industriales
esto quiere decir que cada uno de estos
materiales de hace como una solución que
fue realmente investigada fue realmente
elaborada con la intención de poder
satisfacer una necesidad global dejando
de ver proyectos de una manera
conceptual y utópica
creo firmemente
creo que nosotros como consumidores
generamos las pautas aprendamos a exigir
compras mucho más informadas que nos
digan de qué están hechas las cosas y
nosotros también no deberíamos de tener
miedo de saber cómo nacen los objetos
creo que también debemos de procurar
aquellos que nacen de las nuevas gamas
de materiales y leer e informarnos para
saber si lo que consumimos es
verdaderamente sustentable la única
manera de exigir industrias limpias
geniales y responsables es volviéndonos
parte del requerimiento y volviéndonos
parte del proceso siempre he creído
también que la generalidad de los
agentes de cambio surge a partir de que
nos involucramos en las problemáticas y
no tenemos miedo a ensuciar nos de
verdad meternos a entender qué pasa por
ahí desde el miembro más pobre de una
línea de producción hasta el personaje
más alto en un corporativo y de ahí
poder conectar puntos generar ideas que
realmente sean win-win no se trata de
que pares todo un proceso de producción
tú no puedes para los procesos eso me lo
dijo una persona de un perfil número dos
que son estas personas que son
muy pesimistas no puedes parar en el
mundo eso es verdad pero si quieres
generar un cambio como lo harías
ese ha sido mi reto ese ha sido mi reto
por casi cuatro años cómo generar
cambios que sean realmente positivos
para todos con productos que todos
consumimos entendiendo todos los peines
los dolores que puede tener una empresa
sus posibilidades sus limitaciones y
llevarlo a cabo a una manera accesible
para el público en general
no soy creyente del extremismo por el
contrario creo que si todo cambio debe
ser paulatino para que pueda ser
realmente efectivo
por eso siempre invito a todos a activar
su curiosidad y proponer desde adentro
recuerda tiene que ser paulatino vale
una persona que admiro mucho y que ha
generado un gran impacto en mi vida me
ha enseñado que cada persona tiene una
cosmovisión respecto a la manera en la
que vive pero que aunque vivamos de una
manera individual todos conectamos en
algún punto y bueno yo sé que suena algo
romántico comparado con el escenario que
tendremos en los próximos años pero de
verdad les pido que no abandonen la
lucha les pido que generemos soluciones
que entendamos que una decisión
individual tiene un impacto colectivo
aprendamos a ser resilientes a no
abandonar no seamos cobardes tenemos que
luchar hasta el final y bueno
entendiendo que todos somos un equipo
les dejo una foto en la que salimos
todos
[Música]